um excuse me do you mind if you uh just
drop me off here what whatever you're
okay yeah yeah yeah just drop me off
anywhere thank you
um everything 's fine however just in
future what you said to me was quite
offensive
you asked me where I'm from
I said Vietnam so that's what is her
video
he then said my girlfriend is Chinese so
I try to guess where people are from
because they all look the same to me but
okay
and that's always he said to her in the
Uber let's keep listening about how
you were trying to guess where I'm from
because you think we all look the same
and then you said oh I couldn't tell
like where you were from so because you
look a little bit different that's very
racist I don't I didn't guess the word
could be I said maybe we would be a
little bit different to them but please
don't get me wrong my English is not as
a perfect yeah I
is Chinese and then I love the Asian
people because they're so polite so kind
right videos are like yeah
he's making it worse because because I
understand that I didn't mean
to anything by that but
that comment was a bit off because I can
understand how people can think that
that's off y'all look the same yeah yeah
I can understand that that can be off
like I can understand where it is
but and then you explaining yeah people
and putting in physics no I love
Haitians they don't hate Asians they're
so kind they're so polite they're so you
know
you're digging you're digging Your Grave
Just Let It Go I disagree and I'll say
why what do you disagree about I
disagree that he's digging some grape
that's only a Minds that you have
because you live in a multicultural
country
if I go to any part of Haiti they're
going to talk exactly like this about
other people from other countries all
right yeah if I go to any part of Africa
they'll talk about that like so it's not
an off comment it's only off by your
cultural standards it's off for her so I
can understand how she takes it that way
sure I'm not saying I'm not talking
about where he is in his predicament and
stuff like that sure so I'm not even
talking about where this guy's Islam and
but the way she reacted to that him keep
on going is not going to solve anything
that's what I'm saying I'm not saying
that he's inherently bad or good or
whatever I understand how she's reacting
like that and him furthering more and
trying to explain and be like no cause
you're so kind of this and that judging
by the way she acted on the first
comment he's digging his grave where
he's not making the situation but I I
would agree
I'm saying me as a person if I see
somebody's fresh off the boat I'm not
expecting the geography to look on point
I understand I understand in her uh I
understand in her eyes she may keep she
keeps saying it worse yeah but that's a
really her thing in my opinion when I
see people overreacting to stuff like
this it's just it's like sometimes when
people hang around in like really
liberal circles so they start adopting
all these different pronouns and all the
other stuff and they talk empathetically
to everyone and then they meet somebody
who doesn't understand another [__]
they'll be like you're a man sometimes
that's what control you it's like or
sometimes people are not exposed to any
of this train [__] the same way you are
and so they don't have the language or
even the understanding of the concepts
to even engage with it that deeply they
don't we assume they do because we're on
the internet like that if I go to talk
to my mom about train stuff she does not
get it she does not even know this is a
discussion right so if some trans
individual whatever my mom's like I'm a
woman and she don't really present that
strongly wrong like no you're not
26 sick and this should be like that's
what you don't think so you have to
understand it's all about cultural
references no she she like you guys are
like um you know like a joke see I said
This is My Buddha is that her name to me
I just I think it's odd to be filming it
and then ought to be posting it and
narrating it to be like I went to this
extremely experience it's like is it
really
voila that they there you go is it what
because he doesn't have what the problem
does he because he doesn't know his
geography he has not been exposed to
Asian people like crazy like is that
really right to you come on it's okay to
just say there's some ignorance and
that's why we're all ignorant on certain
things
racism is a bit much and then this is my
girlfriend please don't get me wrong I
love the Asian people there's football
right there yeah so there's a difference
no no the difference there's a
difference between you loving Asian
people and there's a difference between
you saying that we all look the same and
that you are trying to guess where I'm
from because I look different to them to
them is that that's the key word okay
and also you were so you were so quick
to wanted to get out of a car now you're
having a whole film conversation you
know it reminds me of you know when I'm
in stuck in traffic and then someone is
pushing me in like behind me and wants
to pass and wants to pass and then I let
them pass and all of a sudden all of a
sudden it's no longer about one of the
past it's about to like annoying me like
you know you wanna yo you were you were
such a hurry bro and I move and now you
just want to nag me yeah you were in a
hurry go out no don't know and then you
film it teachable moment right I'll say
this it's like
most people are ignorant about places
they don't know about or not exposed to
even right here in this country if I ask
them like what are the difference
between East Africans most people don't
know oh all you East Africans look the
same to me I think I get upset about
that even though I know the difference I
can tell Somali apart from an Ethiopian
or whatnot I could tell a lot of
Africans apart from each other you know
I get mad when people don't know it's
like if you're not used to being around
that you're not going to know and if
you're not used to seeing what Koreans
look like versus Chinese people versus
Japanese you will not be able to tell so
it's just a matter of how often are you
around these people from that culture
and if you're not you won't know
so as you something to be aware of it's
like if I go right now if I go if I go
to Brazil or if I go to Cuba and I just
I just follow the street what are they
gonna say hey and I'll stop Bubba Marley
yes
same same yeah I'll say this you don't
have to tolerate someone else's
ignorance no but I think filming it and
then posting it online to try to
embarrass them and make yourself see I
think that's the way
is it is
it's fine and like I I understand where
you're coming from but at this moment I
don't feel comfortable in this car I'm
gonna get another one I'm really Madam
please forgive me I I really don't mean
it about that but
this company will fire me and I I have a
daughter I swear to God I don't know
this she wrote guilt-tripping me now
or this [__] can get a job
because he doesn't know really English
and he doesn't he's not
it's like just don't report this [__]
because I'm dead if that should happen
because Uber is one of the only places
where I could do a job like I can't do
much so at least at least now he knows
to shut the [__] up the thing is because
he is in a new country yeah
he has to make errors
in order to understand the way we learn
and the way I've learned and I know that
I've been a kid it's fun we could all
claim that race stuff like that and
stuff and that's where you come up with
the point about being malicious and
stuff like that and stuff like that
being malicious yeah no big militias
being actually meaning to be and then
not being malicious yeah where where I
when I was a kid when I was growing up
and I was not malicious about [__] but I
did some pretty dumb [__] some [__] that
I was not supposed to do you're gonna
tell me yeah but he's a grown ass man
he's a grown ass man that is not from
that country and doesn't know so when
you move to another country you have no
codes and you don't know if you go to
China and you tip they will take offense
to that but you need to do it once and
then you learn right or else you gotta
learn somewhere if they don't tell you
you will [__] up
yeah you will [__] up and if you're from
a place that you could be a grown-ass
person but if you're from a place that
is used to tipping you go there you're
gonna offend people you're gonna fan
[__] like that but you know you
gotta you gotta allow people to make
mistakes and if someone makes a mistake
and they apologize just taking their
face at face value maybe they really
didn't know it that's what he sounds
like he's just like I didn't know that
was offensive my bad and you're still
dragging them
because when you are that hurt
she pulled out her cell phone because
she knew this was a moment she could
record you don't get that bothered by
something and pull out your cell phone
to act self righteous yes that's not
hurt yes you do yes you do you actually
do yeah there's people that will be hurt
and be like you know what I need to I
need to do something about that they
will be hurt and they feel like they
need to have something they need to do
something about it and the only way that
they could do something about it is is
film it and shame [__] it's
kind of like an instant reparation of
what they're doing so yeah that person
is acting like someone that is hurt you
could believe it or not but I really
truly believe that she feels hurt some
kind of way and Tyler will hurt it's a
mix of a bunch of things but that person
in some kind of some way feels hurt and
put on the phone just to have like
instant reparation like we gonna make a
teachable moment out of that and we're
gonna put it out there we're gonna put
it on blast that's like a
instant reparation yeah please forgive
me I I I'm the swear to God I don't mean
of this yeah I know like I I'm I
appreciate that you don't mean it from a
bad place and I'm not gonna say anything
to the company I'm just I just want you
I do it wrong now no no no I really I
don't know what what to do I'm telling
you I'm not gonna he picked me up from
my house so I have to choose between
exposing him or exposing my safety worst
case scenario
after being dramatic
and he doesn't know it's your house from
that one Asian comment now we're talking
about your [__] safety he doesn't
know it's your house he picks you up
from a place that you know it's your
house
I'm telling you I'm not gonna say
anything to the company because I
understand that you're saying it's a
barrier of language I get that I get
that but I'm just saying to you in
future just don't say things like that
because it is it's very very offensive
to us
it's fine it's fine I've got a meat I've
got a meeting I've got a meeting to go
to
get down
yes because I don't feel uncomfortable I
don't feel comfortable to be here you
have to respect my wishes I don't feel
comfortable I'm gonna book an Uber
um
thank you
foreign
I think that I think that it comes with
my hurt face but she also is what what
you're saying like for example me I've
been hurt by the police all my previous
encounters for the police so I'm hurt so
there's a way that I'm Gonna Act and
there's a way that I'm gonna have biases
and stuff like that with the police
because of my past with the police and
my president and the police so therefore
I am a herd person I'm not gonna go out
of my way to expose necessarily people
right every cop that ain't counting I'm
not gonna go out of my way and expose
them not all of them but so what you
saying that she does I think comes from
that place of her and then she becomes
what she's saying and I think we're
actually both right on that it's not
just one thing it's not just the other
thing I think the beginning was what I
said and she became what you said okay
that's what I think it's possible when I
hear people talk about stuff like this
and they start calling this racism uh it
makes me just roll my eyes just a tad
bit especially when she's having this
dramatic reaction where she's crying and
stuff like man go to therapy
good you need to toughen up a little bit
if a fresh off the boat immigrant makes
you cry from asking just like oh I don't
know the difference with agents y'all
look the same to me that makes you cry
go to therapy
get some help you have some healing or
some figuring [__] out to do and don't
travel
stay your ass home because if you think
that's crazy go to any country I promise
you culturally speaking they don't know
[__] all about your people so they're
gonna say some stuff that you can be
like what
maybe I'm getting that old man syndrome
but you didn't look you know you live
long enough you just you just hear a lot
you hear a lot you hear a lot and I hear
this I like bro I wouldn't even roll
over in bed for this [__] I would
stay right sweet asleep oh yeah yeah
right in the middle of my dreams this is
not even enough for me to go no I'm
asleep oh yeah that's something fun with
that's enough that's a yeah
that's a nothing three-course meal yeah
I mean um let me start you up with a
little bit of nothing so what would you
like to drink nothing all right for the
main course we have nothing and oh
dessert we have nothing over nothing and
uh with a little Sparkle and sprinkle of
nothing but we know you're gonna get
thirsty so here's this glass it's empty
[__]
that's how innocuous would you would you
like tap nothing or sparkly nothing
she said this man she was afraid for her
safety oh oh [__] if you don't get a
like this man was gonna be ignorant and
attack her man don't know his geography
might be a raper
like I didn't know it was just stop
anyways that's what you want to say it's
too much